Startalk cosmic queries conundrum
edition be their conundrum that's what
we call it Chuck right that's correct
we'll see you start talk Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
this is cosmic queries edition haha
cosmic conundrum well of course we
always have our different inquiries and
I've gleaned from all over the internet
and as usual we start wait we're not
bringing in another expert so this means
I have to know all the answers yes you
do okay fine as like you don't anyway so
[Laughter]
yeah we always start with a patreon
patron because you guys give us money
thank you thank you by the way thank you
for your money
there's no nicer way to say that noise I
just like being direct like that okay
that sounds cool you know thank you for
your money which is what I just want to
say on every birthday and allow me to
say that we're using the money yes to
invent other incarnations of what it is
we do have some which are all in
themselves experiments that we test you
know we battle test them see if they
work refine them and that takes that
takes money that we're not otherwise
getting from sponsors no exactly
I mean it keeps us vibrant it does yeah
the patreon people don't even know
there's stuff that we've done because of
you yeah you know which is cool alright
let's go to Stacy Brown who was our
first patreon patron and she says dr.
Tyson if he were captain of the Starship
Enterprise
where would you go first and why and of
course we have to suspend disbelief and
say that warp is real so traveling at
this beyond the speed of light is now a
capability so now that gives you the the
option to leave this galaxy go anywhere
you want in the observable universe I
would stick in my own galaxy oh because
there's not enough we know about it so
let me just know my backyard first all
righty all right and then I so I would
take a tour around the galaxy okay
right alright once around the block
Jamie was around a block they've left to
the solar systems own motion that takes
about 200 million years for one trip and
so you know that's still fast given the
scale of all of this but but the Sun and
all the planets and all the comments and
all the asteroids and everybody is all
moving around the galaxy together okay
now there's something something happened
on the internet recently of course of
course if we are going around the Sun
right and the entire system is orbiting
the galaxy right it means we don't
complete a closed orbit around the Sun
all orbits are corkscrews right because
the galaxy is also moved well the solar
system is moving it's moving within they
get right so even followed the path so
there was this all this attention given
to someone showing the video of this and
saying well this is a new theory of the
solar system oh my gosh the experts know
this so it's like people this is just
two motions simultaneously right okay if
you do this you go you orbit if you go
that way it's a straight line right if
you do this and that you get a healer
yeah the corkscrew right right so it's
like when you drop a ball on a plane oh
yeah yeah but go straight down to if I'm
watching you the ball actually right
went forward at 500 miles an hour
exactly yeah
yeah it's quick so did you right so it
just went straight down to you exactly
all right so that's cool so I would do
that that's just too but then I'd go
straight to the center and observe the
supermassive black hole dining upon
stars that have come too close
mm-hmm that's what I would do all right
gonna watch the galaxy have a smack okay
there you go Stacy all right let's go to
another patreon uh Tony Tony mirabela
what's Little Miss that is a cool Tony
Mirabella he does sound like a Vegas act
right that's kind of cool tonight only
that's righti Mirabella welcome to the
beautiful downtown Stardust lounge here
in Vegas ladies and gentlemen it is my
to bring to you the one the only Tony
singing before he comes offstage all
right okay
he says what do you think unlocking the
secrets of dark matter could do for us
scientifically would it lead us to being
able to harness it Wow those are two
really big questions how old is he using
some kid in a basement China it's not a
superhero nemesis he's in the making
he's making his own we harness we have
no idea what dark matter is the best I
have my own preferences but my
preferences don't matter what matters is
what experiments are active and in
progress and right now the the going
thinking is that it is a category of
particle that simply doesn't interact
with us electromagnetically so
electromagnetism is like light and
magnetism and all the things that make
atoms stick together as molecules so you
are held together by electromagnetic
forces all right that's why and therapy
twice a week now I don't that holding
you together but physically emotionally
is another thing okay I don't know
what's holding you and yet emotionally
right physically you held together by
electromagnetic forces these this would
be a category of particles that does not
interact with our electromagnetic forces
which means they just pass right on
through like you're not even there right
but did you observe something like the
gravitationally okay so we have we only
know the only reason why we know there's
dark matter here is because well we have
some galaxies but add up all the matter
in those galaxies it doesn't account for
what's going on in this part of the
neighborhood because you see galaxies
from behind whose light gets lanced
according to Einstein's general
relativity and you can ask how much mass
does it take how much gravity does it
take to lens by the
and you come up with a number way bigger
then simply counting the the galaxies
that are there something else is
happening so we call it dark matter
because we don't know what else to call
it
mm-hmm like I said I've said many times
it's really dark gravity right it's
literally dark graphing right we don't
know if it's matter that the folks
betting on it think it is matter and
there's a new kind of particle that we
haven't yet to isolate that's all dad
that's what then so alright yeah isolate
it okay what would you do with it uh oh
you put it in your hand no it'll pass
right through your hand cuz it doesn't
interact with your hand all right so I
don't know how you would contain it how
do you contain it
you would need a Dark Matter box right
so who's gonna make the Dark Matter box
I mean it's a philosophical plant really
it's if there's a there's a thing that
passes right through you what how do you
containing the thing the thing that
passes through everything everything so
everything it passes through right you
need to find something to hold things in
right correct there you go you need
something that interacts not only with
our forces but also with its forces that
that could be yet another frontier of
discovery in the universe what is that
intermediary thing if you were that
civilization right you be badass oh my
gosh you control not only all the
universe that we know about right but
the rest of the universe that's
influenced by dark matter you'd be able
to grab it make dark matter planets out
of it you can make it stick to itself
mm-hmm so yeah that would be a powerful
posture to pervade all right so now take
that and dark energy is that also in the
question oh no that was no it's not in
my answer I answered
I'm Vegas you you answer clearly
Mirabelle's twice I'll move on all right
maybe it'll come up in a different
exactly in a different question you like
don't push it bro all right here we go
at the moon goes from facebook says
[Music]
who's that in Shrek
that's in Shrek really good yeah I love
it
okay so Eduardo says can you explain to
us in mortal language but he's from
Brooklyn named Eddie Shrek for he's in
Park Slope going is somebody going yo
Eddie all right can you explain to us a
mortal language how the boson gives mass
to matter Oh work the Higgs boson how
does it how does it yeah how does it
give mass yeah yeah so let me give my me
attempt this okay that's a lot so neat
to think of mass not as mass in the
traditional sense and not in this
explanation think of it as inertia okay
so inertia in common parlance is that
tendency of something to want to stay in
motion see but it's also the opposite of
that or the inverse of that it's the
tendency of something to not want to
stay at rest okay right okay so inertia
is whatever the things doing it when
that's one wants to keep doing it all
right that's it okay I'm nursing ok lazy
so you can measure the mass of something
by finding a way to measure the inertia
that it that it wields that's okay so
now watch let's go to Hollywood alright
and we'll go to a Hollywood party okay I
used to have a pick and pick an actor
who like no one has heard of that you
know of who acted a couple of things
what if what did you Binet oh please
let's not embarrass anyone um I just did
Kevin can wait okay wait the TV broke it
there we go okay so Chuck nice walks
into a party right
in Hollywood and and the bar is on the
opposite side of the floor okay okay
it's a crowded party all right you want
a drink okay you walk straight to the
bar absolutely you'll get there in 10
seconds of course that was okay
Beyonce walks in okay she wants to go to
the bar
thank God because I'm already there she
wants to go to the bar right but what
happens she begins to accrete correct so
she can't get to the bar in ten seconds
no way she has a very high famous person
mass because everyone wants to be around
her and so her her Posse moves slowly
through the room gotcha
and if you move fast you have low party
inertia
she moves slow she has high party
inertia a resistance to going fast okay
so you have low resistance to go in fast
you just walk right across the thing so
or no resistance
we're not boring or normal just exactly
yeah people exact funky-smelling they
park the way if it's me I go straight
past the bar out the back because that's
how much they actually want make it
sense so far so so there's think of it
as the party field okay okay the party
field is giving mass to the particles
moving through it
gotcha okay that party field is like
because like a big fields there are
party book goers right if the Higgs
field is what they're like the party
goers in lausanne in Los Angeles okay
right so you got that so so if you the
more famous you are the slower you can
move through a crowd because everybody
wants a piece of you right alright so in
that way Beyonce has a very high party
mass you have a very low party mass
correct and every to get everybody else
in between gotcha
so that's kind of what the Higgs field
is doing it is the resistance of to
movement of the particles that pass
through
God first of all it's a just a great
picture you know because we can all
imagine that great depiction yeah and
that is fascinating like who thought of
that I don't know I might have heard it
somewhere I don't remember that's
awesome yeah yeah I mean that's probably
the best way you're ever gonna
understand I think so I think so yeah
yeah that's great mm-hmm that is really
really good and one other little thing
that we learned from Jana uh-huh okay as
friendo star talks at 11:00 Jan 11 lat
grants particles its mass but it's not
most of the mass of the universe most of
the mass in atoms comes from the force
fields inside the atom not from the
particles themselves binding energy of
the of the atoms so so yes it gives
master quarks and electrons and this
order yes the total mass of everything
in the universe is not represented by
the Higgs field it's just the particles
within that are out there okay so just a
little detail and I that was straight I
got straightened out on that by Jana
that's a gold man well that's all really
good stuff man Eduardo I hope that
cleared let's take a quick break we'll
come back more work what you that takes
out in that voice you go
we're back
Startalk
so I'm like I don't have I don't have it
I don't have the which we call that that
is an accent that's okay so that's all
I'm gonna have the accent mm-hmm all
right keep going cosmic conundrum here
we are all right here we go whoa here we
go
Jenny Totten wants to know this she's
coming to us from Facebook hey Neal does
time move faster at the expanding edge
of the universe and slower at the center
now in in there there are some
assumptions that I don't know I don't
know hmm I have to talk mm well the
center part and I don't know mm-hmm
however I love the question in terms of
the expanding edge okay here's something
interesting might not be what you were
thinking all right if you're moving away
from me
right in an expanding universe right and
you have a clock that's ticking seconds
okay if I watch that clock consecutive
seconds will that I observe will come to
me more and more delayed right okay so
when I observe you it will look like you
have slowed down right but as far as
you're concerned you just run stop
that's right that's right so so when she
talked about the expanding edge if
you're gonna watch that edge mm-hmm you
will see things slowed down in that
place right okay but it's not an actual
edge it's not a physical edge it's just
a it's a horizon where you that's all
that is if you go to that edge now
you're in the middle of a new horizon
that is itself whatever distance away it
would need to be but if you did the math
on that right so so if any the way to
answer that is if you want to make any
of that true it's the opposite of what
she said you'd be observing objects
evolve more slowly on the edge the the
expanding edge and you are relative to
you right
yeah gotcha okay that's pretty cool
yes yeah that's that's pretty dope I
gotta say I like that alright let's go
to Virgil Hayward and Virgil says it's
pretty cool man I gotta tell you these
people they're into this we've got good
people we do we got good people to him
he says is there any theoretical way to
destroy a black hole oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you just wait around till it of rapper
[Laughter]
it's an answer it's that answer you just
wait around small ones evaporate faster
big ones like the ones in the Centers of
galaxies that they might take I don't
know a trillion years
oh wait no much longer than that oh yeah
yeah yeah
Google year Google year I'll give it a
Google the Google people is an actual
number yeah and it was a number before
it was the name of a corporation okay
yeah and it's spelled differently goog o
L or Google tell they actually
misspelled it yeah they misspell before
the company right so Google years is a 1
followed by 100 zeros then you could
evaporate the the seriously large
massive black holes in the Centers of
galaxies and yeah then the in that
future it'll be a universe with nothing
because all the stars would have died
the proton would have decayed right so
the very foundations of matter would
have broken up into its fundamental
particle right and really all you have
is particles particles yeah yeah so you
have right the fundamental particles of
the cosmos so universe will end not with
a bang but with a whimper cool and not
in fire but in ice cool literally cosmic
conundrum I see there's a line in and
back to the future
the the second one right where I think
is the second oh the first whichever one
it is Marty keeps saying whoa that's
heavy
oh that's heavy and doc says why do you
keep saying it because it's 1955 why do
you keep saying is heavy
is something wrong with earth gravity in
the future
exactly what I would ask if I were doc I
like that yeah all right let's back to
future one so yeah there you have a
Virgil it's um
wait is your answer we'll just wait at
away for ya yeah that's right we don't
we don't know any way to undo the black
hole right the theoretical way to
destroy this time all right here we go
um all right I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
go with Li Li si Schneider okay from
facebook says which is more likely
extraterrestrial contact Celeste Julie
or inter-dimensionally oh definitely
physically it dimensions we don't wait
no no no no no I want it to be true you
did oh yes but access to higher
dimensions come on now right would I
think we even did a thing on going to
the fourth dimension from the three
dimensions to dimension which does fear
that drops through a piece of paper
exactly and as I've just a interleave
beautiful love that an ounce I do
because it makes things let me describe
it for people Z so so if you have a
intersection of dimensions the
consequences can be extraordinary
yes so if we live inside a sheet of
paper and a three-dimensional being says
I've got this sphere and then we'll even
know what a sphere is all they have are
circles ah ha ha ha right so a circle is
a sphere in two dimensions or a sphere
is a circle in three dimension so you
can say it either way right so if I'm a
mighty three-dimensional creature and I
take a sphere a hollow sphere and I pass
it through your universe right my paper
univ how would you describe this you say
oh there's a dot where did that dot come
from it's mysterious then the dot
becomes a circle right now you only know
it's hollow in the inside because I have
to open up a portal so you can look in
otherwise it's just a you wouldn't know
it's hollow right but anyhow so it's a
circle and what happens to the circle it
grows hmm until what size until it's the
diameter the total diameter of the
sphere all right then what happens and
then it would shrink shrink down and
then becomes a point and it disappears
completely and you have to explain that
to your friends right that is so cool so
imagine a four-dimensional thing passing
through our universe right that would be
how would you even describe you
see a cube show up in the middle of
nowhere and then disappear right that
would be the three-dimensional slice of
the four-dimensional hypercube passing
through our three-dimensional world so
in other words the two-dimensional slice
of the sphere is a circle passing
through your paper world right the
three-dimensional slice through a
four-dimensional hypercube is just a
cube right so the cube will start small
get bigger and then shrink down again
disappear Wow
I don't know dimensions are cool so that
I don't know how to access another
dimension I wouldn't even know where to
begin
so I'm I will bet that we will contact
extraterrestrials before we have before
we know how to go in and out of higher
dimensions right but the ideal it would
be that so here's what I want to tack
onto this though how would they would
know how to observe us but how would we
ever be able to observe if they don't if
they if there are higher dimensions yes
there the higher they could observe us
and we would not even know they know
they were there correct so then you know
okay and so then what we would only be
able to observe is what they are able to
put into our no not to put into it
nothing to pass through it not put in
but pass through for our reality yes I
guess they could put it they could put
it in our reality but it would be so
their reality is so much richer it be
they want to just pass it through right
yeah it's like so let me let me give the
the paper people something to play with
they just draw a circle that you know
right exactly right so we would observe
that we would never be able to observe
their universe but unless we had access
out of our dimensions to their dimension
that's correct
Wow now here's some interesting read
ahead if if you're a two dimensional
being right and you have skin so you
draw the skin mm-hmm
we have an inside okay we three
dimensional beings we'd be able to see
inside their bodies the heart the lungs
the mouth and eyes everything right but
they would not be able to because they
can only see in the paper and they would
just see the outer skin which is just a
line right what that means is a four
dimensional person can see every one of
our
organs at all times I feel so naked I
feel violated see inside your organs
that's cool
so surgery the future of surgery could
be four-dimensional surgery where they
come at you from a fourth dimension and
never have to cut you open
think about that I like it but it's a
sci-fi story right right there gotta
tell you never gonna happen in America
not with this healthcare go that is so
cool well Haley thanks so much for that
question man that's very very cool let's
go with time for a couple more questions
okay Mario Bear Fieri Vieira Vieira
Vieira Vieira Mario Pierre Pierre says
do you think it's possible we'll find
complex organisms like fish in the
liquid water masses in the planets and
moons of he says our souls yeah okay so
first a fish is a way complex organism
all right generally when biologists
speak of complex organisms they're not
talking about fish right they're talking
about multicellular creatures that have
might have some appendages they might
have like at the Cambrian explosion of
life what mom was at 450 500 million
years ago there we went from
single-celled creatures rapidly when the
conditions changed on earth to
multicellular life and that
multicellular life had like limbs and
eyes and and 10 it had features okay
that you could talk about and point to
right generally we call that complex
life okay and then how about how about
it's a single-cell organism but it has
propulsion like no wait am i right
that'd still be simple or single-cell
simple Oh correct rather even if it's
moving even to come to our but we're
talking about I got legs and I got
eyeballs right and I got a nose and ears
that sort of thing that that's complex
features so the question was will we
find something okay I want to find life
in the oceans beneath the frozen surface
--is
the moons of Jupiter and Saturn and I
want there to be life there mm-hmm but
I'm if there isn't you know okay
I'll deal I'll recover but if there is
life it'll be something that swims so
our ocean has many things other than
fish right we have we have Ariel Ariel
you've got spongebob so Patrick Patrick
Squidward
and who's the squirrel sandy that's
right thank you yeah so anyhow where was
it so you're saying if if the life is
gonna be there it's going to have
features and you know you want its life
it could be I mean think about it you
want at least as exotic as the range of
creatures that are exotic our our in our
own ocean exactly and the funny thing is
the deeper you go in our ocean the more
exotic the life becomes you know what
well that unless you've seen it before
unless they've seen you you look
exhausted m2 we gotta take a break when
he come back that was not a compliment
Chuck cosmic queries cosmic conundrums
where we come back
we're back cosmic queries cosmic
conundrum moves very nice Chuck yes sir
bring him on let's just jump right back
into this mm-hmm
this is wrong a good question so far
these are very good questions so far
uh Ross nippled says oh just one thing
about the previous segments question
yeah asking about what kind of life we
might find if we find life we finally in
the oceans I think just there's it's not
only if there's water there all right
okay I do want to get thermodynamic on
you okay okay go for it all right as far
as we know mmm whatever life is it will
require metabolism okay all right it'll
have to process energy in some way okay
for it to process energy in its
environment there has to be a place that
has more energy than in another place
mm-hmm so that there's energy flow okay
exactly like our Sun if the entire ocean
okay we're exactly the same temperature
and there were no water currents and
there was no source of energy we don't
know how life could come to be or exist
or even thrive so life does not happen
without a transference of energy correct
and technically you call that an energy
gradient okay okay that's so that's what
you need all right and and so under
there there's sources of energy from
like the gravitational stress from
Jupiter and from Saturn and other moons
on those moons and that pumps energy
like deep in the center and so so we'll
know if it's hotter in the center than
in the edge then we're good so you mean
the gravitational forces of the planet
that this moon is orbiting yes cause the
tidal forces causes an undulation yes
that creates energy heat yes like when
you bend a paper clip back and forth
I've acted for a better example would be
when they say if you're gonna play
racquetball let's warm up the ball and
what are you doing you it's the ball
squeezing it
information and a refrigeration every
time you do that you're pumping energy
into the ball from your racket that's
what's going on to those moods right now
that's that's dope that's really that's
dope and the hottest moon in the solar
system yeah is called IO and it's
closest moon to Jupiter and it's feeling
this ferociously and it's got the most
ferocious volcanoes the ever work is hot
in the middle the stuff has got to get
out and it it's it's it's hurling and
everything and that is that is basically
from gravity that's that's all Bradley
stress yes stress of gravity pumping it
and it's by the way it's outside of the
Goldilocks zone right so we used to
think oh you need the Sun and it's got
to be just right you know you just need
energy in it right all right okay all
right right look it from facebook says
this right way look it look it that's
the word Roy says hey Neil we're lucky
that's it that's a cowboy name
rodeo okay I'm gonna read this just
because here he goes that's what he says
hey hey Neil
let's talk about low-orbit nice and
that's all he says okay that's cool boy
look it said that he's picking back with
a beer all right so how deep into this
rabbit hole do you want to go I don't
know man all right you ready low orbit
low you ready go I don't think you're
ready I are you ready I'm about as ready
as I'm ever gonna be as ready as you
think you can do for what I'm about to
tell you that's right all right so
doesn't make sense to you that people
this is like inside baseball here okay
just be ready for this okay does it make
sense to you that on earth's equator
mm-hmm
people weigh a little less than people
anywhere else on earth because of the
centrifugal force of Earth's rotation
okay okay the equator is moving the
fastest right basically a thousand miles
an hour okay because we have twenty five
thousand miles in the circumference and
how long does it take earth to rotate
once 24 hours about 24 hours so you
divide those it's about a thousand miles
in an hour about okay all right if you
had a different latitude the circle you
take in 24 hours is smaller right on
down to the pole where Santa's got no
circle at all he's a pure wedding mm-hmm
okay
very nice all right so yes we're
rotating as a solid object but the folks
moving the fasters are right on the
equator and I forgot that I did the
calculation once they weigh about you
know four ounces or about a quarter of a
pound less that's a lot yeah no it's a
lot no it's very easy measure up it's
measurable with a household sketch yeah
I was gonna say okay you were gonna come
up with some light no no micro no no no
it's real it's real okay okay that's
good that's cool all right far so good
so let's spin Earth faster all right
they'll weigh even less okay poor Santa
his weight doesn't change at all right
because first of all he's fat no he's
just pure wedding of course so there's
no there's no center before it's on the
pole right all right so we're tiffin now
you weigh a pound less mm-hmm kilogram
like how or whatever is your favorite
unit we just keep doing this and you can
ask yourself at what speed must I rotate
Earth so that you don't weigh anything
you'll just float there on the equator
that's it askable question isn't it if
I'm spinning you up and you're waiting
less and less and less right you know
what speed that is what you rotate the
earth once every 90 minutes every night
instead of 24 hours
yes it's an hour and a half an hour and
a half and everything on earth would
just know everything on the equator
everything only a quaver cuz that's
right wait it doesn't ways it's okay
right all right the other stuff doesn't
have as much centrifugal force right all
right
no no go ahead okay I'll keep going so
if I'm on the equator now and my feet
aren't even touching the grounds I'm
just floating right yet somehow I'm
staying with earth as you had always
been even up to that moment correct up
to that moment you're there now you just
wave one pound you can jump high but
you're still rotating with earth you
rotate earth a little extra and now
you're just floating well I just
described for you or Oh low Earth
orbit
you know I forgot that that's where do
you know how long it takes the space
station to orbit the Earth 90 minutes so
that Wow is that good that makes sense
is that good that's good that's an orbit
I love okay so low Earth orbit is not
now of course low Earth orbit in
practice you want to be in above above
enough of the atmosphere so you're not
you know burning up through the
atmosphere Christ we're gonna be high
enough so that you go up 100 kilometers
it's about 60 miles you're hiring up
above most of the atmosphere so that you
can now orbit the Earth faster than the
earth would take you and that's and you
complete one orbit in 90 minutes if you
write exactly above our surface it's
actually 88 minutes okay all right 80 if
you do the math 88 minutes you go up to
where it's space station is about 90
minutes guys okay all that's low Earth
orbit Leo we call it leader action at
low Earth orbit yeah you go a little
higher up right 500 miles up that kind
of thing you get to me Oh mm hmm hmm
medium earth Middle Earth orbit okay not
Middle Earth right but middle-earth
middle okay
right and there you'll find the GPS
satellites okay all right so they'll do
an orbit it'll take longer than an hour
and a half but slower than 24 hours okay
okay then you go a little higher you get
Geo mm-hmm geosynchronous orbit so these
are orbits where oh no you can do the
opposite and say if I go farther away
I can stay in orbit with a lower and
lower speed okay and here's earth
turning beneath my feet is there a
distance where I can orbit exactly with
the rotation of the earth so that I take
one orbit in 24 hours yes there is its
23,000 miles up and it's called
geosynchronous orbit and there's the
synchronicity there's a synchronicity so
you launch that I saw it you just hover
is overhead
that's very cool and if you park one
park between Europe in the United States
you can beam signals up to it and you
can talk too beyond the curvature of the
earth that's it Elon Musk wants to
launch constellations of satellites so
that you don't have to beam out to
23,000 miles you know why because if you
be in a light signal 23,000 month
that's far enough away that the
round-trip you notice that in education
it's a way there's a lab it's all AG
you'll notice it and sometimes you'll
see it in a broadcast or even a
sometimes you've been on a phone and
there was a lag that's probably hitting
a geosynchronous s so so communication
you want the satellites to be lower
right but if it's lower you're not
always in view of it right because it's
orbits out of your zone it doesn't stay
with you think tonight if once this goes
everything you want another one coming
in right behind it right that's why a
LAN is launching hundreds of satellites
so that everyone has fast internet and
with with no lag cool yeah well thank
you Elon and and thank you
Roy Roy luck it Roy lucky bamboo I
didn't know that was such good quick
yeah leo is right there that was so how
much time much time again I don't know
what one minute one minute all right all
right here we go
Chuck you got time for one more question
make it a good one all right or make it
a bad one we'll turn it into a good one
okay Shawn for Farook says this is a
faraway planet if a faraway a planet
emits a light of low frequency and light
of high frequency which one of them will
win the race and reach us first
oh the speed of light in a vacuum does
not discriminate by frequency boom there
you go however
if it goes through a medium mm-hmm
it does gotcha and it is because
different frequencies move through media
at different speeds mm-hmm that the
colors manifest after it comes through
so if you put light through a prism
mm-hmm and you put it it at the right
angle at the correct angle the white
light comes in and the prism says blue
you're coming out birth red you're
coming out last I'm spread and went and
since it's spread since they goes
through a different speeds all the
colors reveal themselves as they come
out of the prism there you go
separating in separate yes so that so so
the prism is what is is glass right that
will air will separate the colors right
Diamond does it the best is that it's
the most transparent it's the most it's
the densest transparent thing we know
okay so that'll do it the most slows
down the light the mother than any and
and it slows down like by its to 40% of
its vacuum speed of course that makes
sense which is when you look at a
diamond and it refracts all the light
you like before all the pretty colors
right that's what's going on and it is
better than glass does right that's why
diamonds are diamonds and glass or glass
right right don't tell my wife that
cubic zirconium get you halfway there so
so different frequencies of light do
travel at different speeds through a
medium and just just to make that clear
and so now they are there is medium in
space like gas clouds when light comes
through there you get this effect right
that you get this effect and you can get
a time lag in an explosion if the
explosion happens in multiple
frequencies you'll see it having at one
frequency before it doesn't another and
we have coordinated our telescopes to
check for this nice you have a radio
telescope a visible light telescope
infrared telescope and you can see
phenomenon if it's coming through a
medium that will differentially slow
down the frequencies of light no that's
very cool that is excellent yeah but in
a vacuum it says
so that's it to tie the light is a sweet
Eliza like that's very cool
okay Neil deGrasse Tyson and Chuck nice
yeah Startalk cosmic queries keep
looking up
[Applause]